Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Denise RQ
Nei prossimi 15 minuti
ho il piacere di raccontarvi
una delle più belle avventure
di cui ho fatto parte,
una storia che incontra
mondi completamente diversi:
la fisica, la matematica,
la meccanica statistica,
le neuroscienze,
l'agricoltura, la politica.
È una storia che include 30 ricercatori
che hanno lavorato
per due anni per rispondere
a una delle più grandi
sfide del nostro futuro:
come sfamare sette miliardi di persone?
Ora, come tutte le grandi avventure,
partiamo dal primo capitolo: la sfida.
Il cibo è uno dei mercati più complessi
che l'uomo possa immaginare.
Nella produzione del cibo è incluso tutto:
le biotecnologie, la genetica, la chimica,
l'industria, i trasporti, l'energia,
il vostro cervello come vedrete,
i dati, i mercati, la finanza,
il marketing, i brand.
Qualsiasi cosa possiate immaginare
è inclusa nel cibo,
è ad oggi una delle attività
più importanti che facciamo.
Fondamentalmente,
gli esseri umani, ancora oggi,
per quanto Facebook e Twitter funzionino,
mangiano e cercano di restare vivi.
Questa è un'impresa
eccezionalmente complessa,
tanto che gran parte
dei governi ha bisogno
di supportare i mercati alimentari
in maniera massiva.
Questo è uno dei grafici
che faccio vedere spesso:
quanto la Comunità Europea
spende direttamente
per aiutare l'Europa,
i cittadini europei, a mangiare.
Il 50% dell'intero budget
della Comunità Europea
è speso semplicemente
per aiutare a produrre cibo,
per assicurarci qualcosa da mangiare.
Questo è un modello
che negli anni '90 funzionava,
quando i mercati erano
relativamente semplici.
Sfortunatamente, negli ultimi 20, 30 anni
i mercati del cibo sono diventati
di una complessità incredibile.
La globalizzazione, che conoscete tutti,
fa produrre oggetti da una parte
del mondo e mangiarli dall'altra parte:
trasformazioni e finanza,
prodotti derivati, sono diventati oggi
uno strumento quotidiano
delle grandi aziende alimentari,
e sfortunatamente,
i governi iniziano ad avere
sempre meno soldi,
sempre meno supporto diretto.
La Comunità Europea ha dovuto ridurre,
e tutti gli stati 'non treat'
del Trade Organization
hanno dovuto ridurre l'intervento diretto.
Sfortunatamente, quando hanno iniziato
a ridurre gli interventi
gli agricoltori non avevano
più soldi per produrre,
e quello che vedete in mezzo alle piazze,
alle strade, è esattamente questo sintomo.
I grandi governi iniziano adesso
ad affrontare la nuova sfida
di come assicurarci il cibo
per i prossimi 50 anni:
i modelli vecchi non funzionano,
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa.
Allora ci hanno chiesto
di lavorare su una tecnologia,
su un qualsiasi sistema che potesse
aiutare i governi a prendere decisioni.
Adesso vi faccio vedere
dove eravamo nel 2010.
Quelle che vedete qua sono
modelli di previsione dell'USDA,
il Dipartimento Agricoltura Americano.
Nel 2010, hanno tirato
fuori delle previsioni
di come sarebbero andati
tre dei più grandi marker
- mais, soia e frumento -
del mercato alimentare.
Come vedete previsioni di prezzi
stabili, previsioni anzi al ribasso.
Sfortunatamente,
i mercati sono andati così.
Quella che vedete nel 2010
è una delle più grandi spike,
delle più grandi crescite
dei prezzi delle commodity del mondo.
Quando una di queste cose succede,
non è come l'aumento
di uno stock in borsa:
quando il prezzo del cibo cresce,
la gente va in strada e spara.
È l'inizio della guerra:
quando le persone non possono
mangiare, non hanno più strategia.
Questo è l'inizio dell'Arabic Spring,
e questi sono gli inizi
dell'instabilità globale.
L'abbiamo visto nel 2010, credevamo
non potesse succedere, è successo,
abbiamo bisogno di qualcosa di più.
Abbiamo bisogno di un piano,
e questo è il secondo capitolo: the plan.
Ora, uno dei grandi approcci
che abbiamo visto negli ultimi anni
e che avrete visto e letto sotto il nome
di Big Data, Machine Learning
e Intelligenza Artificiale,
è che fortunatamente siamo
in un'era sufficientemente digitalizzata
per provare a capire come le cose
funzionano guardando i dati.
Ma dobbiamo raccoglierne
una mole vergognosa, gigantesca,
al punto da chiamarli Big Data:
terabyte e terabyte di dati.
Quindi il nostro piano
è esattamente iniziato così:
prima cosa, raccogliamo dati.
I dati sono ovunque.
Raccogliamo dati per qualsiasi cosa,
per certificazioni,
per rendicontazioni, per tracciabilità:
ci sono dati del cibo da tutte le parti.
Sappiamo quante banane
vengono prodotte in Burkina Faso
-se vengono prodotte in Burkina Faso-
sappiamo quanti pezzi di carne
vengono importati e esportati:
i database sono ovunque.
Sfortunatamente, ogni database
ha il suo indice, il suo nome,
il pollo è chiamato chicken,
è chiamato pollo,
è chiamato qualsiasi altra cosa:
le ali di pollo hanno 360 denominazioni,
e ci sono pezzi
che devi incollare da tutte le parti.
Questi si chiamano
dati sporchi, dirty data.
Abbiamo speso gran parte
del nostro tempo a raccoglierli
da tutte le parti: Fao,
World Bank, Stati Uniti,
database europei, database nazionali,
scontrini nei supermercati.
Abbiamo costruito il più grosso
database che esista oggi al mondo
di dati alimentari di tutto
il pianeta, letteralmente.
Adesso vi faccio vedere che cosa
vuol dire fare previsione,
ne facciamo una insieme.
Non sarà molto difficile,
ma vi faccio vedere
la storia di un prodotto
che conoscete: il vino.
Vedete il grafico, la linea arancione
è il volume di vino
venduto in Italia negli anni
di vino confezionato sfuso,
diciamo il vino di più bassa qualità.
Il volume inizia a decrescere negli anni,
iniziamo a bere vino di più alta qualità
e ha una leggera oscillazione stagionale.
Iniziamo a vedere i vini
più importanti, i D.O.C:
quello che vedete nero, là, è il prezzo.
Il prezzo inizia a crescere,
è un prodotto più stagionale,
è un prodotto con una certa periodicità.
Adesso vi faccio vedere
un'altra cosa: lo spumante.
Vedete quei picchi arancioni?
Bene, quello è il Natale;
il secondo picco è Pasqua.
Non vi servono 22 ricercatori
e delle grandi menti per capire
che questo è uno
dei prodotti più semplici,
forse, da predire,
da cui fare forecasting;
ma una cosa altrettanto
interessante, capite, è il rischio:
se qualcosa succede in quelle
8 settimane, avete chiuso,
tutto il mercato è in quelle 8 settimane,
tutto il mercato è Natale.
Per quanti spritz possiate bere
fuori, agli aperitivi,
il 90% delle vendite
avvengono a Natale e Pasqua.
Come questa piccola storia del vino,
abbiamo dati di qualsiasi cosa:
da mele a energia,
ogni singola commodity
che conosciamo, in un paniere di 6.000,
in ogni singola nazione
negli ultimi 10 anni,
aggiornate certe volte giornalmente.
Allora un altro esempio, un altro studio
che vi faccio vedere, curioso,
è la storia di come girano i dati.
Immaginate di avere
22 ricercatori che parlano
- io sono un fisico teorico, quindi parlo
di meccanica quantistica, di numeri:
a un certo punto ti trovi a parlare
di ali di pollo, o stinco di maiale,
e perdi la concezione di che cos'è,
e allora una cosa
che abbiamo voluto vedere
è come funzionano
questi mercati, la dinamica:
cioè cosa vuol dire
comprare una banana in Italia?
Bene, comprare una banana
in Italia vuol dire questo.
Questi sono tutti i tragitti che possono
essere fatti attraverso le dogane
per trasportare una banana
sulla vostra tavola a novembre.
Quelle rosse sono i più probabili poi,
pian piano, fino al blu, i meno probabili.
Certe volte ci sono salti di 4 nazioni.
Uno dei più grossi importatori
di banane in Italia è l'Olanda.
Ovviamente non vengono prodotte
in Olanda, le banane,
ma quello è quello che vedi dai dati:
devi ricostruire la rete
per cui questi oggetti
si muovono da una parte all'altra.
E questa fotografia va bene
per un giorno, va bene per un mese;
ma ogni mese cambia
a seconda della stagionalità,
certe nazioni saranno a dicembre,
certe nazioni importeranno a giugno,
quindi c'è un'oscillazione
in quest'enorme trading,
in quest'enorme rete di scambi.
Ma se c'è un'oscillazione,
possiamo misurarla,
e possiamo vedere
come questa foto cambia nei mesi,
possiamo costruire un indice, si chiama,
e possiamo vedere quanto il fatto
che voi vogliate una banana
a novembre, a Milano, perturba il mondo,
quanto il mondo deve lavorare,
e decidiamo che se il mondo
deve lavorare troppo
il valore deve essere basso,
è poco sostenibile,
se il mondo lavora poco, cioè
se questa rete è abbastanza piccolina,
decidiamo che è un prodotto sostenibile.
Questo è un oggetto che abbiamo fatto,
si chiama Trade Impact Index,
e potete farlo girare
per ogni nazione e per ogni prodotto.
Vi faccio vedere un esempio, gli agrumi,
o i meloni, o il caffè.
Questi sono i prodotti,
questo è l'indice di sostenibilità,
questo è quanto la rete globale
deve lavorare in funzione del mese,
per portarvi questi prodotti
sulla tavola, every day.
Ora non ci vuole - io non sono
un grande esperto di stagionalità,
lo sono diventato.
Ma non ci vuole un genio per scoprire
che gli agrumi è meglio mangiarli
d'inverno, o i meloni d'estate:
ma questo algoritmo l'ha imparato,
e per ogni zona del mondo sa esattamente
che cosa è meglio, o peggio,
mangiare in quella specifica zona.
E siccome noi siamo nerd,
per noi ogni cibo,
ogni oggetto è un numero, o un'equazione;
e anche una ricetta,
per noi, è un'equazione.
La ricetta è una somma pesata di elementi.
E ogni elemento ha
il suo indice di sostenibilità.
Allora ci siamo detti,
qual è il piatto più sostenibile
da mangiare in Italia?
Qual è il piatto più sostenibile
da mangiare ogni giorno, in Italia?
Abbiamo scaricato tutto
il database delle ricette italiane.
Per quanto voi possiate essere
meravigliosamente eclettici in cucina,
50.000 ricette sono
quelle che compongono
il nostro background culturale
e alimentare in Italia.
E di queste 50.000 ricette
ne abbiamo presa a caso una:
lo stracotto di maiale.
L'abbiamo scomposto
in tutti i suoi elementi,
ne abbiamo calcolato la sostenibilità,
e ci siamo chiesti,
ma cosa possiamo fare noi
per essere un pochino più sostenibili?
Abbiamo costruito una rete semantica,
e abbiamo visto tutti i piatti
che sono simili allo stracotto di maiale.
Alcuni sono gialli, alcuni sono rossi,
alcuni sono verdi: lo spezzatino di manzo.
Ora, dentro a quella ricetta
ci sarà un elemento,
magari una pera, una carota,
qualsiasi altra cosa,
che, nel momento in cui lo incapsulate,
dovete far lavorare per voi un'intera
rete mondiale di persone per portarvelo.
Una singola carota magari,
un singolo pezzo di frutta.
Bene, quello che abbiamo
costruito è un indice
che vi permette di rivedere
questa complessità in un colpo solo
e darle un colore, e far vedere
che, dentro alle ricette
che ci sono nella nostra cultura,
basta certe volte cambiare
qualche elemento
per ridurre la complessità
e ridurre lo sforzo del pianeta.
L'altra cosa che abbiamo fatto
è iniziare a fare le cose 'hardcore',
iniziare a predire
come funzionano i mercati.
Vi faccio vedere che cosa vuol dire.
Predire significa prendere
la storia di una commodity
- quella che vedete è la storia del riso-
cancellarne un paio di anni,
non considerarli mai,
allenare gli algoritmi
più sofisticati che potete pensare
e vedere se quel paio di anni
riuscite a ricostruirlo, ok?
Questo è il primo pezzo,
dopodiché dovete andare "live",
dovete andare nel futuro e iniziare
ad aggiornarlo giorno per giorno
per vedere se veramente funzionano.
Quello che vedete qua in basso
è quel pezzettino che abbiamo tolto
dalla lunga serie storica.
Ma nella lunga serie storica
abbiamo la fortuna
di non avere solo il riso,
di avere tutte le commodity del mondo,
di vedere quanto il riso
è correlato con le pesche,
o quanto è correlato col mais,
o quanto è correlato
con il costo dell'energia.
Utilizziamo tutte queste cose
e facciamo quello
che si chiamano modelli di 'machine
learning', ma senza esser tecnici.
Quello che vedete qua è
il risultato del nostro primo modello
a 4 settimane.
Siamo abbastanza bravi
a predire, a quattro settimane
quale sarà il prezzo del riso,
e anche quel picco del 2010
siamo riusciti a vederlo.
A otto settimane iniziamo a perdere
un pochino di correlazione,
ma siamo sufficientemente
ancora bravi a prendere il verso.
Tuttavia c'è un problema,
e questa è la sorpresa.
Ci sono delle cose
che non sapevamo predire, in nessun modo.
Ad esempio l'aviaria.
A un certo punto, per uno scambio
di informazioni nei giornali,
il mercato del pollo, in due settimane,
ha perso l'80% delle vendite.
È una cosa complessissima
da vedere nei dati, perché è 'one time',
e deriva da una dinamica sociale.
Quindi quello che abbiamo costruito,
e abbiamo scoperto,
è che non è nei Big Data
il grande segreto del cibo,
ma negli Smart Data,
è dentro al vostro cervello.
Abbiamo ricostruito
un modello semplice di mercato
dove il produttore dà
al distributore, dà al consumatore,
e la governance interagisce
con tutti questi player.
Quello che abbiamo scoperto
è che è un mercato di tempi.
Il produttore ha dei tempi molto lunghi,
ci mette 10-15 anni
a pianificare un'industria;
il distributore ha tempi medi,
può riorganizzare la logistica
in un paio di mesi;
il consumatore, voi, non avete tempi:
potete uscire dalla porta
e diventare vegetariani,
e non avete neanche il bisogno
di fare la chiamata di cortesia
all'industria alimentare
e dirle, guardate
che non mangio più carne.
Non avete tempi, potete
cambiare istantaneamente strategia.
E come fate?
Be', questo lo fate attraverso
un lunghissimo processo
di ottimizzazione neurocognitiva.
Quindi, quello che abbiamo
fatto, abbiamo voluto,
è aggiungere al modello la capacità
di vedere dentro al vostro cervello.
Abbiamo costruito un database di immagini
di ogni cibo che siamo
riusciti a raccogliere.
Si chiama Frida DB,
e abbiamo studiato, in funzione
del vostro stato cognitivo,
come reagite al cibo, se,
quando c'è una crisi alimentare,
preferite andare su cibi naturali
o sui cibi industriali,
se quando siete madri
o siete giovani, rispetto agli anziani,
come valutate il cibo,
come riusciamo a predire
o cercare di capire
un'eventuale instabilità che arriva.
Vi faccio vedere un ultimo grafico
che è molto carino
e che vi riconduce indietro
a qualche centinaia di migliaia di anni,
sentendo il primo talk.
La eccezionale capacità
del vostro cervello
è che ha una stratificazione storica:
questa è la prima scoperta
che abbiamo fatto, ed è carina.
Il vostro cervello ha ottimizzato
la ricerca del cibo nella foresta
e ha scelto, e sceglie spesso
di mangiare cose rosse
rispetto che verdi o giallastre.
È una cosa atavica, antica:
ci aiutava a selezionare meglio
i cibi andati a male dai cibi sani.
Curiosamente, questa vostra attività
non funziona soltanto
in oggetti che hanno stagionalità,
come le mele, ma nella pasta.
Quindi, a parte i genovesi che forse
sono affascinati dal pesto verde,
in generale il vostro cervello reagisce
in tutti questi layer storici
in maniera assolutamente
complessa e non banale.
E l'unico modo che abbiamo avuto,
e capito, di chiudere il processo
è ripartire dagli Smart Data
e aggiungere voi nell'equazione.
Questa è l'inizio
di una storia ancora più lunga,
che faremo nei prossimi anni.
È stato un piacere raccontarvela.
(Applausi)